♫ Like the heather ♫
♫ on the hillside ♫
♫ as they drove us ♫
♫ from the Highlands ♫
♫ Like the ice flow ♫
♫ from the Arctic ♫
♫ where we landed ♫
♫ in Newfoundland ♫
♫ There's a color ♫
♫ to my sorrow ♫
♫ There's a name for ♫
♫ all this sadness ♫
♫ Like the ocean ♫
♫ in between us ♫
♫ I am blue ♫
♫ Blue is a river ♫
♫ Blue remembered ♫
♫ Blue water ♫
♫ running clear ♫
♫ Blue like a planet ♫
♫ to a spaceman ♫
♫ Blue river ♫
♫ of my tears ♫
(Fiddle and synthesizer)
♫ So I came here ♫
♫ to the city ♫
♫ where the dream burns ♫
♫ like a furnace ♫
♫ And I dazzled ♫
♫ in these dark streets ♫
♫ like a diamond ♫
♫ in a coalface ♫
♫ Then the cold wind ♫
♫ from the islands ♫
♫ blew a storm cloud ♫
♫ across the new moon ♫
♫ Like the gun smoke ♫
♫ above the houses ♫
♫ in my home ♫
♫ Blue is a river ♫
♫ Blue remembered ♫
♫ Blue water ♫
♫ running clear ♫
♫ Blue like a planet ♫
♫ to a spaceman ♫
♫ Blue river ♫
♫ of my tears ♫
(Fiddle and synthesizer)
(Applause)